I want to follow up about the YouTube
advertiser boycott crisis the david
pakman show youtube channel has had its
revenue cut by over ninety eight percent
okay and I'm going to you and our
audience for help this jeopardizes the
status quo of the david pakman show it's
been a very tough couple of days here
very long days 14 15 hour days and i
want to give you the latest information
and the latest information is that five
days into this advertiser boycott it is
crushing our show and many others there
has been a collapse of the revenue
stream that was flowing to youtube news
& politics channels with some exceptions
that we don't understand there are some
channels that are doing very
controversial news in politics material
ads are still running i don't know why i
have no idea why this is destroyed what
was the great thing about YouTube the
great thing about YouTube was it's an
open forum if you build an audience you
will reap the rewards if you get more
views more ads run and you make more
money success is rewarded you never talk
to advertisers you just make content
youtube brings the advertisers ads pop
up and we get some money for the show
that we produce day in and day out it's
also great because advertisers can't
influence us there's no way we could be
selling out because we don't even know
who we're selling to the ads that appear
from day to day depend not on what we're
doing but they depend on what companies
are advertising it's in a sense it's a
great system as long as we're not doing
nudity porn profanity or gore we do our
stories ads pop up we never talk to the
advertisers and sometimes the ads would
be completely counter to the position
that we took on the show like will
criticize the pharmaceutical company and
the lo and behold there's a
pharmaceutical company advertisement
before the video or we doing a video in
favor of gun control and an ad for an
anti-gun control group pops up and
that's because we are not in any way
coordinating with the positions of the
advertisers what happened is that some
tiny YouTube channels had ads run that
due to error just skirted YouTube's
filter system and some coke ads appeared
on racist videos there's a handful of
examples
and then there were some big media
articles including one by the wall
street journal that said look at this
outrage it caused advertisers to pull
out YouTube shut down almost all ads on
channels like ours I couldn't find a
single ad on our channel yesterday and
if it weren't for YouTube super chats
and YouTube red revenue our YouTube
channel revenue yesterday would have
been this is not an error I'm not
missing any zeros here Pat six dollars
six dollars for our 14,000 video library
on YouTube and all of this is to fix a
problem that doesn't really exist this
ad boycott made YouTube create an
algorithm that is insanely strict right
almost anything we discuss is too
controversial for monetization if we're
activating against anti-semitism if
we're activating against religious
discrimination or against Isis the mere
mention of religion or Judaism or
Christianity or Islam or Isis makes it
so that the videos don't earn money at
first i thought the cut to our revenue
was about 80% then I thought oh you know
it looks like about eighty-five percent
then I said you know it looks like
ninety percent of our revenue has been
cut the truth is that 95 to ninety-eight
percent of our revenue has disappeared
effectively overnight for people who are
watching if you look at the most recent
four days it looks like zero it looks
like we have earned zero because we
effectively have again yesterday the
YouTube channel from ad revenue making
six dollars the proof is right there in
front of you this revenue may never come
back we don't know right if this is the
new normal and we don't replace this
revenue we're done this could not be
worse this is great for corporate media
they're loving it because when GM pulls
50 million at a YouTube it's in their
budget they're going to spend it in 2017
they just call up comcast or NBC or
MSNBC or CNN or whoever and they just
move the money so we could great for
corporate media we're the ones who are
losing out here and we don't know if
that was the goal of the wall street
journal and the other websites that
we're writing our
close about this but that was certainly
the effect either way that the effect is
what matters and people emailed me
saying David make the entire show
members only so everybody has to pay
that goes against every principle I have
the whole point is we produce the show
and it's out there for free and only
about 1% of our audience actually pays
through membership or patreon but that's
okay because the goal is we subsidize
the production for everybody through the
people that are that are able to donate
but I want to do everything we can to
keep everything exactly the same right
so let's see if we can replace the
revenue and we've got a three-pronged
approach I mentioned this yesterday
number one membership david pakman.com
slash membership number to patreon
patreon.com slash david pakman show and
number three whenever you shop on amazon
you go to david pakman.com slash amazon
you can even bookmark the link and that
will send us a five to seven percent cut
of your purchases i want to focus today
on patreon okay for people watching this
is what the patreon website looks like
ok this is super super easy you just go
to patreon.com/scishow and you click
become a patron we started with
something like 40 patrons we got to
about a hundred and fifty patrons during
the youtube live stream last night we
got all the way up to 275 patrons and as
of an hour or two ago we had surpassed
350 patrons because this is growing and
we can keep this up for a second path
and because membership is growing I am
starting to think we might be able to
actually do this if we do not replace
the lost revenue we're screwed period
and many people have found I opening
when I mentioned that of our entire
audience we estimate that only about 1%
of the audience actually contributes
financially and I said if we can move
that to two and a half or three percent
we eliminate the need for a single
dollar from YouTube and so that's why
I'm encouraging you membership is sort
of like the insiders way to support the
show and you get benefits and perks and
the bonus show patreon is the way to
publicly show up at patreon.com slash
david pakman show and make that number
of patrons
amount donated per month pick up a
little bit okay even if it's just a
dollar or two please go to
patreon.com/scishow the goal is to get
to 500 patrons and add patrons sort of a
word for donor were we're closing in on
400 I want to get to 500 that's the next
goal please throw in what you can and
just deserve just as you a message of
hope we've had a lot of people call in
saying I am increasing my contributions
here's one caller who said that hey
david this is greg from Connecticut um
just signed up for the membership at
your website after seeing your story
about the YouTube advertisers boycott I
know I probably speak for a lot of
people when I say that shows like yours
are kind of the only sense one can find
today in these troubled times and i look
forward to getting more content from you
in the future and hopefully supporting
everything that you do thank you i'm
inspired by these calls that have been
coming in here's one other caller who
had a similar feeling about the whole
thing hi David this is Rachel Amy and
little conservative town Indiana and I
have doubled my membership goal to help
you in the YouTube crisis and I
encourage other people to do so as well
thank you very much we're talking about
a couple pennies for each video we
produce we're talking about 25 or 50
cents for each one hour podcast please
go to patreon.com/scishow vid packs show
the silver lining is if we can replace
the lost revenue we will be stronger
than ever because we'll have the same
revenue without any reliance on youtube
to decide whether they monetize or not
the topics we're talking about send me
your thoughts about what's going on i'm
on twitter at d pakman we will take a
break and be back after this